dove cazzo ma non è questa riuscita la
cazzata
cos'è un ascensore per il centro della
terra che cazzo succede ragazze dove
sono avevate promesso che quella era
uscita stranzi dove sta andando spesso
vado no va bene cos'è cerca un'altra
uscita ma se siamo al ci siamo sbloccati
in cina un altro po dove che assume che
esca ma dai non scherziamo lo sapevo io
tanto lo sapete cos'è
ragazzi siamo pur sempre in un manicomio
e cos'è sta roba l'umbrella corporation
mio dio sembra veramente steel umbrella
corporation non so perché
vabbè io io non ha idea di che cosa sia
sta roba ma c'è gente c'e sangue ovunque
il che non non mi consola per niente
come faccio sia di qua andiamo avanti
così dove siamo dove dove cos'è so cos'è
cosa c'è gente a terra morta cosa è
successo
ragazzi che cazzo eco posto è
esageratamente diverso da tutto il resto
del gioco cioè non c'azzecca un cazzo
con l'ambientazione di prima
vabbè comunque è pieno di sangue il che
mi consola parecchio va la mente non so
come faccia uscire di qua non penso ci
siano altre uscite perché pieno di
sangue non lo voglio sapere perché è
pieno di sangue ragazzi quella è una
futura uscita a prima porta
siamo evidentemente su marte perché è
impossibile che si sa che
l'ambientazione fuori però va beh
usciamo dico perché veramente non so che
cazzo sta succedendo del ai veri exit
ragazzi si può uscire
si no
[Applauso]
chi cazzo sei ragazzi di è questo ok non
so chi sia questo c'è un fantasma che mi
segue dove ghostbusters ragazzi c'è un
tizio non so chi è non hai da lì chi
cazzo si sa ma mi sta seguendo e sta
porta si deve aprire assolutamente
apriti apriti veloce
no c'è un [ __ ] posto di merda sì sì
sì ma dritto nel kaprun titolo deve
mettere tutto a tutto stronzo di merda
devi morire
mio zio
questo è una versione di follia fatta
ma chi cazzo è questo mio dio ma questo
qua è peggio di di frisardi di sel luce
dopo non lo sconfiggerebbe mai
penso che sia un nuovo cattivo di dragon
ball o qualcosa del genere
no questo è veramente fantastico ma so
chi cazzo si sa c'è qualcosa di epico
ammazzato l'obeso che è riuscito a
raggiungerli dovunque anche nelle
catacombe cioè non ho idea di chi sia
quel tizio ma mi ha salvato il culo in
una maniera incredibile mi togliete per
favore l'allarme ragazzi mi sa che devo
tornare indietro perché l'allarme non
sono riuscito ha disattivato infatti qua
è aperto non era aperto prima
no no fermi fermi lo so lo so dovrei
essere morsi welfare non ho questa
fortuna sono un vecchio decrepito ma in
qualche modo sono l'unico sopravvissuto
tutto grazie a billy questo qua il tizio
che faceva gli esperimenti su tutti i
pazienti aprista porta demente nesta mi
hai fatto staccare due dita stronzo si
prende cura di me ha rimosso un cancro
dello stomaco mi ha sistemato gli occhi
forse crede che io sia suo padre è stata
una follia è un errore pensare di poter
controllare il processo di poter usare
dei pazzi perché lei qualcosa di così
potente non sono riuscito a frenare la
mia curiosità non facciamo in tempo a
leggere ma va bene sapevo che ci avrebbe
distrutti tutti ma non ho resistito devi
fermarlo devi uccidere billy stacca di
supporto vitale l'anestesia deve
riparare al mio errore
cazzo evil infisso di prima
finché sarà vivo nessuno potrà uscire di
qui devi ucciderlo io dove riparare i
tuoi cazzo di errori va bene aprista
porta cerca billy nel laboratorio
principale chi è billy non so se quella
giusta ma credo di si aspettava un
attimo che nel no ma stavano chiudere ma
perché mi chiudete dentro [ __ ]
ragazzi non hai dall ici cazzo sia sto
billy non ha idea di dove sia
soprattutto ma io voglio la mia [ __ ]
nutella o noi speriamo di trovarli in
qualche modo che schifo eh va beh noi io
io non italy di dove sia sto tizio
perché c'è gente
distrutta a terra mio dio si può
togliere la l'allarme che prima non
c'era uscita [ __ ] gullo chi è
questo no dai cazzo ma preso una molla
mi grazie visto stuprando di brutto
togliti ok mi ami ha aperto in quattro
tutti chiesto tiki cos'è cos'è starò
cos'è non ho idea di dove si sia andato
a ficcare no no no no no no no ok ok ok
ok ok non è passato
non è passato sì bene possa girarlo
forse ragazzi sto tizio attraverso le
porte sono eccessi no togliti togliti
vaffan
ok perfetto ragazzi aiuto sponda st
porta ok aspettate dopo stadi 4 roberto
strada ancora dietro di me non lo so
ragazzi qui no no no no no non ti
incastrare qui fuori che attrae sì ce la
faccio la faccio ci posso credere
la musica mi metto una tensione
incredibile che tizio popolare
mi pare di sì non lo so comunque smesso
di seguirmi ha smesso di seguirmi penso
di sì chiudi st porta maledizione
ma bondi dobbiamo trovare il [ __ ]
pighi che non so dov'è ma da qualche
parte praticamente credo sia il tizio
che controlla sto mostro quini nolana
giacché capito che mi ha detto il
dottore ma penso di sì
aprite bravi così ragazzi mi sono sempre
un convinto di essere su marte perché
non lo riconosco sto posto il tizio è
per caso da queste parti
chiudi la valvola le riserve di fluidi
non ho letto interno faccio mai in tempo
né eco bobby o billy nomi cornacchia più
come si chiama diciamo che non se la sta
passando molto comoda è a più di una
cannuccia devo staccare da qui no da
dove devo staccare non lo so chi sei tu
amico mio che dammi una mano ma dimmi
dove devo andare di qua di qua di c
grazie mille ci prova ma qualcuno ha
esploso perché pieno di sangue non so
chi fa qualcuno è uscito ragazzi che
cazzo devo fare è la stanza dei fluidi
riserva credo sia questa devo
disattivarla lo sprint e ragazzi il mio
compito e scassare tutto devo
distruggere qualsiasi cosa credo la cosa
brutta è che c'è quel tizio di merda che
continua a seguirmi è il che non è un
bene per niente ragazzi devo devo
distruggere a perfetto la valvola la
valvola di sicuro serve qualcosa se non
avrebbero fatta no no non girare la
valvola e non fate io cosa faccio
maledetti stronzi dovete farmi uccidere
la gira volentieri non so cos'altro devo
fare di preciso però vabbè i fluidi sono
andati a [ __ ] quindi già qualcosa
cos'è cos'è cos'è dov'è dov'è quel tizio
ragazzi non lo vedo non lo sto vedendo
vado avanti perché non lo sto vedendo ma
c'è qualcuno dietro di me di sicuro suv
laboratorio ragazzi ci siamo devo
scassare qualcos'altro qui dentro fatemi
scassare qualcosa gli scienziati non
saranno più al sicuro
arriva a favi spacca tutto come passo di
qua lo fare un salto assurdo non so se
ce la faccio
sì mio dio sono sono mamma mia sono un
jumper quando vedo un cazzo lo devo
proseguire in qua no [ __ ]
lo sapevo cori stronzo i tory
maledettissimo come si fa di qualcosa
passare apre sì non ci credo non ci
credo non ci credo
mi sono salvato per un culo incredibile
ragazzi ce la posso fare
baba boy comunque non me lo spiego come
fa ad essere ovunque sono un po
attraversa alle porte cos'è sta roba
spaccato tira via cavi chi se ne fotte
disattiva la procedura d'emergenza della
bio camera di billy ragazzi dobbiamo
tornare indietro non ci posso credere
si no cos'è lo sento lo sento da qualche
parte l'ho sempre ad cos'è no
togliti le mandò gli le mani di dosso
mai detto turno o mio dio cosa sto
facendo
ragazzi mista ammazza sono morto sono
sono sono caduto da 450 metri sono
ancora vivo come cazzo è possibile c'era
come come ho fatto su come ho fatto a
sopravvivere
c'è ma vi rendete conto di che cazzo di
caduto fatto cenno come faccio essere
ancora vivo impossibile
vabbè sono vivo questo è l'importante
corri maledettissimo stronzo corrie ce
la posso fare se non posso fare sì sì sì
l'ho fatta anche senza un dito magari
maledetto stronzo morissette i film o
anche e lo metto su youtube
cosa fa donatogli ti stai per morire
maledetto stronzo stai per morire non
sbattermi al muro come credo che stia
per morire non lo so forse non ho capito
un cazzo magari di un centro nulla mi
ammazza uguale ragazzi vista trucidando
non so se effettivamente quella così che
doveva andare forse a deve morire prima
il tizio noir in fretta fuori muori
maledetto trovandolo morire quello nella
boccia misa mari maledetto stronzo mori
prima che mi ammazzi fuori si è morto è
morto
grazie a dio è morto
ragazzi siamo vivi siamo caduti rea 500
metri in totale ma siamo ancora vivi
senza due dita per vorrei aggiungere ce
la fa ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi ci
abbiamo fatta è morto è morto stronzo
sei morto es nuovo obiettivo è sì ma mio
dio ma secondo te quale cazzo è stato il
mio obiettivo sin dall'inizio andare in
disco pub ma mio zio ma sei stupido
allora ragazzi sono stoppi kahn dopo
cioè non riescono manco a muovermi cioè
io io devo arrivare devo arrivare ai
corsi fino all'entrata ma neanche mi
reco in piedi ma come faccio arrivare
così a all'ascensore raga ma stiamo
scherzando
dai tirati suo amico hai finito
hai finito tutto abbiamo fatto ogni cosa
e sei sopravvissuto a obesi altri
aspetti non si sa chi cazzo erano a tizi
col birillo di fuori a tutto
addio festa persino che sei crocifisso
dai ceppi il mio 6 alla fine sei caduto
da tre chilometri prima non ti sei fatto
un cazzo
adesso che sei caduto da una distanza
molto più piccola ti sei fatto così male
ma scherziamo dai che ce la puoi fare
non mollarmi non farmi rammollito la
soluzione amico mio è piccarsi 2
peperoncini nel capra anzi come ha fatto
lo spettro un episodio fa mi paro questo
episodio non uso quando avete visto voi
sono solo un essere umano
solo un essere umano che cazzo fate solo
non stiamo scherzando
la slot mi ha ucciso sei bastardo ma non
gli hai detto che ti ho salvato il culo
no non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere
[Applauso]
sono morto sono sono morti non avete il
[ __ ] diritto di far finire così un
videogame non potete sono scappato
dovesi da da tizi cosa di fuori non
potete uccidermi alla no ma stiamo
scherzando sono morto veramente uniche
persone sane di mente che ho incontrato
mi hanno sparato ma stiamo scherzando
dottori pazzi che in italia non le dita
obesi ma mi ami ami ami ha ucciso la
slot e zigon 2 cazzo e stricker 2 perché
questo è stato il gioco horror più figo
che io abbia mai fatto in tutta la mia
vita è questo veramente ragazzi è stato
un capolavoro outlast è stato non solo
all'altezza delle aspettative ma molto
molto oltre
nonostante il finale che probabilmente
stasera passerà la nottata a tirare
d'estate all'armadio e spero che voi mi
facciate compagnia perché non è
possibile
spero che la serie vi sia piaciuta
perché a me sinceramente è piaciuta
tantissimo nonostante il mio cuore non
sia d'accordo con me mi è piaciuto un
casino
ciò anche ragazzi se la serie è il video
vi sono piaciuti
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che come nani video
trovate la descrizione server iscritti
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo il prossimo
video beh ragazzi
[Musica]